vimos que para una masa que oscila en un
resorte tenemos cierta amplitud que será
la distancia máxima o desplazamiento
máximo de la posición de equilibrio pero
también habrá cierto periodo que es el
tiempo que le lleva a este proceso
reiniciarse es decir el tiempo que le
lleva a esta masa recorrer el ciclo
completo pero de que dependen estas
cosas conocemos sus definiciones pero de
que dependen para la amplitud es algo
obvio la persona va a jalar hacia atrás
la masa quien sea o lo que sea que esté
desplazando esta masa hacia atrás es lo
que determina la amplitud y jalamos la
masa más lejos le daremos a este
oscilador una mayor amplitud y si sólo
lo jalamos un poquito le daremos una
amplitud menor pero algo menos obvio en
términos del periodo es de qué depende
este periodo quién o qué determina el
período quizás depende de la amplitud
veamos
si yo les digo que jalamos esta masa más
atrás
aumentando la amplitud mucho más lejos
que esto esto afectará el periodo de
este movimiento veamos algunos de
ustedes quizá piensen que se debería
aumentar el periodo ya que ahora tiene
más distancia que recorrer en lugar de
recorrer esta cantidad ahora tiene que
recorrer esta otra más grande y ya que
tiene más distancia que recorrer el
periodo debería aumentar pero algunos de
ustedes quizás digan a ver un momento si
jalamos más lejos esta masa sabemos que
la ley de hook dice que la fuerza es
proporcional la fuerza del resorte es
proporcional a la cantidad que se ha
desplazado el resorte así que es hija lo
más lejos esta masa va a tener una mayor
fuerza lo que ocasionará que esta masa
tenga una mayor velocidad una mayor
rapidez cuando pase por aquí por lo que
se va a mover más rápidamente de lo que
lo haría si la halláramos menos
distancia y ya que se mueve más rápido
quizás les lleve menos tiempo
recorrer esta distancia pero resulta que
ambas características se equilibran
exactamente es decir el hecho de que
esta masa tenga más distancia que
recorrer junto con el hecho de que ahora
va a viajar con más rapidez se
equilibran perfectamente y no nos va a
afectar para nada el periodo esto es
algo loco pero es algo que necesitan
recordar los cambios en la amplitud no
afectan el periodo para nada si jalamos
esta masa hacia atrás aunque sea un
poquito va a oscilar con cierto periodo
digamos que de tres segundos para hacer
este problema un poco menos abstracto
ahora digamos que la jalamos hacia atrás
mucho más su oscilación seguirá siendo
de tres segundos tendrá más distancia
que recorrer pero lo hará más
rápidamente así que la amplitud no
afecta al periodo de una masa que está
oscilando en un resorte esto es algo
loco pero es cierto y es importante de
recordar la amplitud no afecta al
periodo
esto en una gráfica gráfica moss esto si
aumentamos la amplitud que va a pasar
pues se va a estirar de esta forma en
esta gráfica podemos hacer esto sin
tener que modificar el periodo podemos
aumentar la amplitud o disminuir la pero
el periodo se puede mantener igual si
solo cambiamos la amplitud el periodo no
se va a afectar así que los cambios en
la amplitud no me van a afectar el
periodo entonces qué es lo que afecta al
periodo si la amplitud no lo afecta
entonces que lo va a afectar veamos
primero la fórmula del periodo la
fórmula del periodo de una masa en un
resorte este periodo va a ser igual a 2
espn multiplicada por la raíz cuadrada
de la masa que está conectada al resorte
dividida entre la constante del resorte
y es la misma constante de resorte que
tenemos en la ley de hook y es la misma
que vemos en la fórmula de energía de un
resorte todas son la misma constante del
resorte esta es la fórmula para el
período
de una masa en un resorte y no vamos a
derivar esta fórmula porque las
derivaciones normalmente involucran
cálculo si conocen cálculo y quieren ver
cómo se deriva a esta fórmula vea los
videos que tenemos sobre movimiento
armónico simple usando cálculo y verán
de dónde sale esta fórmula pero aquí
solamente vamos a usar tal cual esta
fórmula y a comprenderla tenemos este 2
pi y luego tenemos aquí en masa y porque
el aumentar la masa incrementa el
periodo esto es lo que tenemos aquí si
aumentamos esto de acá que es la masa
vamos a aumentar el periodo ya que
tenemos un numerador más grande aquí lo
que tiene sentido ya que una masa más
grande tendrá mayor inercia
incrementamos la masa y esta masa va a
ser más pesada y se va a resistir un
poco más al movimiento si fuera una masa
más pequeña podríamos estar la moviendo
de manera más fácil pero es una masa
grande a la cual va a ser difícil
cambiarle la dirección del movimiento y
debido a esto le va a llevar más
por recorrer esta distancia de todo un
ciclo ya que para el resorte va a ser
más difícil mover una masa más grande
después volverla a mover al lado
contrario porque es más masiva y tiene
más inercia es por eso que aumenta el
periodo y le lleva más tiempo completar
un ciclo y esto tiene sentido con
respecto a la masa qué pasa con este
valor de acá esto también tiene sentido
si aumentamos el valor de acá nos va a
dar una mayor fuerza del resorte para la
misma cantidad de distancia desplazada
si aumentamos el valor de acá la fuerza
de este resorte va a aumentar por lo que
podrá jalar con más fuerza y empujar con
más fuerza también así que vamos a
ejercer una mayor fuerza en esta masa lo
que hará que ésta se mueva más
rápidamente por lo que una mayor fuerza
significa que podemos hacer que esta
masa recorra esta distancia mucho más
rápido y es por eso que el aumentar la k
me va a disminuir el periodo ya que si
podemos mover esta masa más rápidamente
nos llevará menos tiempo que recorra un
sí
y esto a veces confunde a las personas
que el que lleve más tiempo signifique
que tenga un periodo más grande algunas
personas piensan que para que esta masa
se mueva más rápido debe de tener un
mayor periodo pero no es lo opuesto si
movemos esta masa más rápidamente le va
a llevar menos tiempo moverse por lo que
va a disminuir el periodo y es esto de
lo que depende el periodo de una masa en
un resorte recuerden que no depende de
la amplitud aquí no hay nada de amplitud
el periodo sólo depende de la masa y de
la constante del resorte nuevamente aquí
no derivamos esta fórmula o explicamos
de dónde sale si quieren saber de dónde
sale esta fórmula los invito a ver los
vídeos en donde se explica de dónde sale
la fórmula o usar cálculo algo más que
es importante notar esta ecuación
funciona aún cuando la masa esté
colgando verticalmente si tuviéramos a
esta masa colgando del techo algo así y
esta masa oscila verticalmente
y va abajo esta ecuación nos seguirá
dando el periodo de una masa en un
resorte aquí ponemos la masa que tenemos
en el resorte ponemos la constante de
resorte de este resorte y esto nos
seguirá dando el periodo de esa masa en
ese resorte es decir esto no depende de
la constante gravitacional aquí tampoco
vemos a la g minúscula esta minúscula
hará que esta masa cuelgue un poquito
más abajo de su posición de equilibrio
pero no va a afectar al periodo lo cual
es bueno esta fórmula no sirve para
masas horizontales y para masas
verticales nos dará el periodo en ambos
casos en resumen el periodo de una masa
en un resorte no depende de la amplitud
podemos cambiar la amplitud pero no
afectará el tiempo que le lleva a esta
masa recorrer la distancia de un ciclo
completo y esto se cumple para masas en
resortes horizontales y masas en
resortes verticales el periodo tampoco
depende de la aceleración gravitacional
así que si llevamos
saco resorte a marte oa la luna y
dejamos que cuelgue verticalmente si es
la misma masa y el mismo resorte el
periodo va a ser el mismo no va a
importar cuál sea la aceleración debida
a la gravedad pero el periodo si es
afectado por la masa en el resorte y por
la constante del resorte una mayor masa
implica un mayor periodo ya que hay más
inercia y una mayor constante acá va a
implicar que va a haber más fuerza en el
resorte que va a poder mover más
rápidamente la masa y por eso tendremos
un menor periodo